[Musique]
premier constat de cette conférence
beaucoup se connaissent déjà la sécurité
alimentaire n'est pas un thème nouveau
pour les pays membres de la commission
de l'océan indien
mais depuis 2016 et les premières
conférences avoir pas non les choses ont
évolué un ton âme
l'organisation de l'onu présents dans le
cadre de la fin on à l'organisation
africaine aussi présente et nous allons
mener un programme croisé avec l'europe
oui on avance oui sur les programmes
2021 et 2027
nous souhaitons que l'europe s'y soient
partenaires de ce projet de sécurité
alimentaire dans la zone de l'océan
indien
nous espérons sur la base des problèmes
qui sont mis en place que dans les
prochaines années on pourra
véritablement avoir un marché commun
chaque école dans l'océan indien avec la
participation de tous les saints pays
parce que bien sûr le focus c'est sur un
score mais chacun de ces pays présentent
des avantages et des produits qui
pourraient également partagé avec l'exil
en fait c'est de s'assurer si je peux le
dire de façon basique que que dans
chaque dans chaque famille qu'on puisse
avoir un repas par jour loin des caméras
habillée pour l'occasion une délégation
malgache s'installe discrètement 1,17 et
70 ans
c'est la première fois que ces
agriculteurs quittent leur village et
donc leur pays enfin que les martiens
méthodes là
les techniques traditionnelles de
l'actuelle ça ça ne convient plus à un
autre et johanna du mat à sion donc nous
ferons les changements quoi la
production qui c'est de se dire avant de
nourrir les autres pensons d'abord à
nous nourrir nouvelle et peut-être on
aura peut-être moins d'argent qui
rentrera mais peut-être vivre à beaucoup
miel ce qu'on produit avec la qualité de
ce qu'on produit plutôt fait d'avoir
l'argent qui très souvent est très très
rare dans leur poche parce qu'il faut
savoir que la colle des collecteurs
l'agachon peu scrupuleux
chacun dans sa singularité doit avoir
une alimentation accessible de qualité
et stable dans le temps raison pour
laquelle le cirad experts techniques de
cette france dans l'océan indien a
présenté tour à tour les projets
structurants de coopération régionale
tous les blés les projets effectivement
que l'on met en oeuvre sont issus d'une
analyse des besoins des pays on a monté
une plateforme qui s'appelle la
plateforme de recherche en agronomie
tropicale qui a dont le premier objet a
été effectivement d'aller dans les pays
de discuter avec les partenaires pour
essayer de discuter quelles étaient les
vraies priorités en matière de sécurité
alimentaire de ses priorités
donc on traduit des programmes de
recherche qui évidemment se déroule et
ce aujourd'hui se décline à travers nos
réseaux de coopération
prochaine étape la validation du
développement des produits phares dans
chaque territoire dans le respect des
réglementations de tous mais surtout
aujourd'hui dans une volonté collective
affirmé des états souverains
[Musique]